I'LL BE IN TOUCH WITH YOU AFTER
THE SHOW AND THANK YOU AGAIN.
REACTION TO THIS STORY, WE ARE
JOINED BY TEXAS SENATOR TED
CRUZ.
SENATOR, I WENT LONG IN THE
INTERVIEW AND I'M SORRY BECAUSE
I TOOK SOME OF YOUR TIME.
BUT A GREAT FAMILY FROM TEXAS.
THEIR LIVES HAVE BEEN TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN AND HEARTS BROKEN.
THEY DON'T EVEN GET A CALL FROM
THE FORMER MAYOR OF SAN ANTONIO
WHO WAS ON TV TALKING ABOUT THIS
CARAVAN THING AND DEMONIZING
DONALD TRUMP AND ALL REPUBLICANS
AND DIDN'T EVEN GET A CALL FROM
HIS BROTHER WHO IS A CONGRESSMAN
FROM AN AREA WHERE THIS KID WAS
BURNED THAT THAT.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY, SENATOR  ?
>> LAURA, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
MISSED VARGAS ON AND TELLING
JARED'S STORY.
HEARTBREAKING, TRAGIC, IT
SHOULD'VE NEVER HAPPENED.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THE DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS TURN A BLIND EYE TO
THE SUFFERING, THE VIOLENT
CRIMES THAT ARE COMMITTED.
I WAS GLAD TO HEAR HER DESCRIBE
THAT SHE'S BEEN ABLE TO WORK
WITH CHIP AND HE'S MY FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF AND HE'S THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR CONGRESS
OUT OF SAN ANTONIO.
GOING TO MAKE A TERRIFIC
CONGRESSMAN.
MISSED VARGAS SHOULD NOT BE
SUFFERING.
THIS INDIVIDUAL, THIS ILLEGAL
ALIEN, COMMITTED MULTIPLE CRIME
CRIMES.
AND ALL REVOLVING DOOR SYSTEM
LETS DRUG CRIMINAL, VIOLENT
CRIMINALS WHO ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS
STAY HERE.
YOU'VE GOT A VOLUNTARY REMOVAL
ORDER WHICH HE IGNORED.
IT'S THE REASON WE NEED TO PASS
CASE LAW, WHICH I'VE AUTHORED IN
THE SENATE, THAT SAYS AGGRAVATED
FELON, VIOLENT CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
ALIENS WHO ENTER THE COUNTRY
REPEATEDLY SHOULD FACE A
MANDATORY MINIMUM PRISON
SENTENCES SO VIOLENCE, CRIMINALS
WILL NOT BE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: THIS WAS A DWI --
>> WE SHOULD'VE DEPORTED HIM
WHEN HE HAD A DWI.
HE SHOULD'VE BEEN SENT OUT OF
THE BUS DOWN THE COUNTRY.
WE SHOULD NOT BE KEEPING -- TOO
MANY TEXANS, TOO MANY PEOPLE WHO
LOST LOVED ONES TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE CRIMINALS WHO
COMMIT DWIS AND IT'S WRONG.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR COUNTRY
AND NOT ALLOWED CRIMINALS AND
DRUG DEALERS INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: YOU DID A FANTASTIC
JOB IN YOUR DEBATE WITH
MR. O'ROURKE.
A TOWN HALL TONIGHT AND I WANT
YOUR REACTION.
>> SPENT THE REST OF THE DEBATE
RESPONDING TO EVERY SINGLE
DISHONEST THING HE SAID OR I
COULD MAKE SURE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S DOING.
LOOK, HE'S DISHONEST.
ONE OF THE REASONS HE GOT TAGGED
WITH THIS NICKNAME.
THAT NICKNAME RESONATES BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE.
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS I
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS G
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS E
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS S
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS H
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS '
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS S
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS Q
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS O
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS I
>> Laura: OBVIOUSNESS G
THE PRESIDENT IN ORDER TO MAKE
HIS CASE.
SEEMS LIKE THERE IS NO -- HE'S A
GOOD-LOOKING GUY, BUT THERE IS
NO THERE THERE.
WHERE IS THE BEEF?
>> YOU CAN SEE THE DESPERATION
IN THAT DEBATE WHERE HE WAS
INSULTING ME, ATTACKING ME, CALL
ME A LIAR.
WHAT'S STRIKING WHAT HE WAS
RESPONDING TO WHEN HE SAID LIAR
I POINTED OUT THAT HE VOTED IN
FAVOR OF A $10 A BARREL TAX ON
EVERY BARREL OF OIL IN    PRODUE
EVERY BARREL OF OIL IN    PRODUD
EVERY BARREL OF OIL IN    PRODUI
EVERY BARREL OF OIL IN    PRODUN
THE STATE OF TEXAS.
HIS RESPONSE IS NOT TO ENGAGE
BUT SCREAM, LIAR, LIAR, LIAR.
FACTS MATTER, AND WE PUT UP ON
OUR WEBSITE TedCruz.org THE
EXACT TEXT OF THE RESOLUTION
THAT CONGRESSMAN O'ROURKE WILL
VOTED ON.
BROUGHT UP A RESOLUTION SAYING,
WE DON'T WANT A $10 TAX ON EVERY
BARREL OF OIL AND O'ROURKE.
>> Laura: SENATOR, WE ARE OUT